bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je voulais
vous faire une petite vidéo pour vous
parler des prix nobel donc les prix
nobel 2016 qui ont été annoncées cette
semaine et ben j'avais envie de vous les
commenter un petit peu donc je vais
évidemment parler que des prix nobel dit
scientifique
je vais parler du prix nobel de médecine
du prix nobel de chimie et puis du prix
nobel de physique
on va commencer par le prix nobel de
médecine cette année il a été décerné à
un japonais qui s'appelle yoshinori eaux
soumis pour ses travaux sur ce qu'on
appelle l'autophagie alors qu'est ce que
c'est l'autophagie bas si on prend la
racine grecque du moa autophagie ça veut
dire se manger soi même et donc
l'autophagie en fait c'est un mécanisme
qui existe au sein des cellules qui
permet d'éliminer et de recycler des
choses alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
donc déjà on est tous se fait de
cellules dans tous les organismes
vivants sont fait de cellules et au sein
d'une cellule en fait on trouve tout un
tas de choses alors vous avez peut-être
déjà vu dans des livres de bio par
exemple un schéma d'une cellule est donc
dans une cellule on trouve tout un tas
par exemple de protéines qui permettent
d'assurer un certain nombre de fonctions
et puis de construire aussi des
structures et on trouve tout un tas de
structures qu'on regroupe sous le terme
générique d'organites et il arrive
qu'une cellule soit toujours
parfaitement fonctionnel mais qu'elle
ait un certain nombre de protéines ou
d'organites qui soit par exemple devenu
obsolète ou bien qu'ils soient dégradées
abîmé et donc qu'elle ait besoin de se
débarrasser de tout ça et donc
l'autophagie c'est un mécanisme qui
permet de faire ça ce mécanisme il a été
découvert il ya assez longtemps déjà
puisqu'il a été découvert par un belge
qui s'appelle christian de duve qui
avait déjà eu le prix nobel dans les
années 70 et donc le principe de
l'autophagie c'est celle suivant
imaginons que vous ayez des protéines ou
bien enfin un organite dont dans la
cellule veuille se débarrasser la
cellule va commencer par construire
autour une paroisse sous la forme d'une
double membrane pour enfermer ce dont
elle souhaite se débarrasser qu'on
appelle un auto phagosome et ensuite
cette auto phagosome il va être mis en
contact avec avec une autre type de
véhicule qu'on appelle un rhizome qui
contient un certain nombre d'enzymes qui
est dans un milieu assez acide qui sont
capables de digérer ce qui a été
enfermée dans l'auto phagosome
c'est-à-dire de digérer et de décomposer
notamment les protéines nous voyez que
le loto phagosome c'est pour prendre une
analogie en quelque sorte le sac
poubelle de la cellule est donc ce sac
poubelle est amenée en contact avec le
lysosome qu'on pourrait comparer par
exemple à un centre d'incinération des
déchets alors en fait c'est pas tout à
fait un centre d'incinération des
déchets puisque la beauté de la chose
c'est que ce mécanisme d'autophagie en
fait il permet de recycler la matière
première c'est à dire que les protéines
sont dégradées mais on récupère les
briques de base
elles peuvent être réutilisés par la
cellule pour refaire des nouvelles
protéines et j'avais lu ce chiffre il
faudrait que je retrouve la source parce
que je sais plus exactement d'où ça
vient mais quand grohl le recyclage du à
l'autophagie dans un corps humain
typique ça représentait à peu près 200 à
300 g de protéines
vous imaginez que si ces protéines en
fait elle était simplement dégradé est
éliminé ça voudrait dire que pour
assurer notre besoin en protéines en
fait on devrait manger chaque jour 200
ou 300 g de protéines en plus que ce
qu'on mange déjà week c'est quand même
un mécanisme qui est assez efficace
alors du coup au smic est ce qu'il a
fait dans cette dans cette histoire je
vous ai dit ce pas lui qui a découvert
le mécanisme de l'autophagie c'est grâce
à lui qu'on l'à beaucoup mieux compris
et qu'on a notamment pu comprendre
comment certains gènes jouer un rôle là
dedans et en fait aux souvenirs il a
procédé à une manière qui est assez
intéressante
la première chose qu'il a fait c'est que
il a décidé d'utiliser non pas des
cellules humaines ou des cellules
animales mais de la levure de boulanger
vous avez peut-être que contrairement à
la levure chimique qui est juste un
produit chimique inerte la levure de
boulanger et 20 sedc des organismes
unicellulaires et c'est un organisme
qu'on utilise assez souvent quand on
veut étudier des phénomènes de de
biologie moléculaire et cellulaire
notamment quand on veut utiliser des
phénomènes qui sont assez basiques et
qui existent un peu je suis tous les
organismes alors du coup on utilise la
levure de boulanger parce que c'est
assez pratique
donc il a utilisé la levure de boulanger
est en fait ce qu'il avait envie de
faire c'était de faire des images de
regarder au microscope ce qui se passait
et le problème c'est que les mécanismes
de l'autophagie en fait on les voit on
ne voit pas très bien ces deux c'est
petit ça dure pas longtemps et donc
qu'il a eu il a eu deux idées en fait la
première c'est de la femme et c'est
levure de boulanger c'est à dire de ne
pas leur donner de nutriments et du coup
quand on donne pas de nutriments quand
on affame les cellules comme ça ça
stimulant fait lotophages il faut
imaginer les cellules elles ont besoin
de l ont quand même besoin de matières
premières elles ont besoin d'énergie
elles ont besoin de protéines et donc
bah si on leur en donne pas en fait ça
va stimuler le mécanisme de recyclage
pour qu'elle essaie de gratter là où
elles peuvent donc il a stimulé
l'autophagie chez la levure de boulanger
en les affamant et puis l'autre truc
malin qu'il a fait c'est qu'en fait il a
désactivé le mécanisme des enzymes qui
sont qui sont qui sont donc dans le
lysosome un nom dans cette structure qui
contient les enzymes qui vont faire la
digestion des protéines ce qui fait que
en fait d'un côté il stimule
l'autophagie dont qui stimule le
recyclage des déchets si vous voulez et
de l'autre côté en fait il désactive
lusinchi est chargé de faire ce
recyclage et donc qu'est-ce qui se passe
eh bien il se passe la même chose que ce
qui se passerait chez vous si jamais les
éboueurs passait pas les sacs poubelles
s'accumulent et donc il a pu faire comme
ça des clichés de levure de boulanger où
on voyait dans les cellules tout un tas
de d'auto phagosome du coup s'accumuler
puisqu'il pouvait pas être
digérée par par les enzymes du lysosome
et c'est comme ça qu'il a pu mettre en
évidence ces autos phagosome
qu'autrement on avait beaucoup de mal à
voir parce que leur existence était
assez transitoire ça dure c'est à dire
seulement quelques minutes le temps que
le temps que ça soit normalement ensuite
digérer et donc une fois qu'il a mis au
point cette cette méthode
ça lui a permis de très bien visualiser
ce phénomène est donc il a pu l'étudier
et notamment étudié les gènes qui
étaient impliqués et la manière dont il
a fait ça c'est que il a engendré un
certain nombre de mutations dans les
gènes de la levure de boulanger il a
regardé ce que ça a changé ou pas au
phénomène d'autophagie est comme ça il a
pu identifier une quinzaine de gênes qui
manifestement avait un rôle déterminant
pour pour l'autophagie et ensuite il les
a étudiées un parent en essayant de voir
quel était le rôle exact de chacun des
gènes voilà et donc donc voilà la
contribution de deux doses uni qui nous
permet de mieux comprendre le principe
de l'autophagie sachant que le principe
de l'autophagie il est quand même
important notamment du point de vue
médical puisqu'il ya un certain nombre
de maladies qui peuvent être associés à
des dysfonctionnements de de ce
mécanisme
donc voila voila pour le prix nobel de
médecine
alors on va passer au prix nobel de
chimie on va commencer par un petit
cocorico parce qu'il a été décerné à
trois personnes dont un français jean
pierre sauvage donc qui travaille à
l'université de strasbourg et donc le
l'objet du prix nobel de chimie cette
année c'est elle et ce qu'on appelle les
machines moléculaires
qu'est ce que c'est une machine
moléculaire mais en gros c'est l'idée de
fabriquer une des molécules qui se
comporte un petit peu comme comme des
machines qu'on a à notre échelle
c'est à dire qu'il soit quand elle
défère d'effectuer un certain nombre de
mouvements bien contrôlé en réponse à un
stimulus par exemple à un apport
d'énergie alors sur le papier on
pourrait dire on a envie de penser que
ce n'est pas très compliqué quand il
s'agit de faire des molécules qui mime
un peu des machines en fait si on
regarde un petit peu plus plus profond
en fait c'est compliqué j'essaie vous
expliquer pourquoi
si on prend une molécule j'ai pris un
petit un petit modèle de molécules crois
que c'est la caféine je sais plus très
bien en fait une molécule on voit ces
faits de liaison et du coup l'ensemble
et finalement quand même assez rigide je
peux prendre la molécule bon
paul à tordre un peu mais voyez je peux
pas effectuer des rotations par exemple
avec où je peux pas effectuer des mots
des mouvements tels qu'on aurait par
exemple avec des roues
si on s'amuse à faire la comparaison par
exemple j'ai pris juste un petit peu de
petits bouts de lego technic vous voyez
ici j'ai un axe et puis mon axe peu peut
tourner et c'est quoi la grosse
différence en fait entre entre ça et une
molécule normal on va dire c'est que bah
du coup la molécule elle est rigide tout
est lié avec tous et donc on peut pas
avoir des mouvements du type de celui
qu'on a avec voilà avec un axe qui
passeraient qui passerait dans un trou
voyez bien que ici l'acce en fait et le
bout de lego ne sont ne sont pas liés en
fait ils sont contraints quand on les
met ensemble mais sont pas liés donc si
on veut espérer faire quelque chose qui
ressemble à des machines à l'échelle
moléculaire
il faut qu'on arrive à mi mai ce genre
de principe est donc ce qu'il faut qu'on
fasse c'est faire des molécules dont
certaines parties ne soient pas liés par
des parts des liaisons chimiques mais
soit simplement enchevêtrés comme on a
pu l'avoir ici avec avec l'axé la
briques de lego
voilà je vous montre un exemple assez
des molécules qui n'existe pas mais
c'est juste pour vous montrer en fait
j'ai deux molécules qui sont deux formes
un peu circulaire comme ça et on
pourrait imaginer que ces molécules
soient soit entrerait en shv aytré et
donc quand on a deux molécules qui sont
enchevêtrés comme ça voyez qu'elle peut
avoir des mouvements libres et pourtant
elles restent elles restent quand même
ensemble des molécules de ce genre là en
fait on sait en faire donc ça s'appelle
des caténaires et en fait la question
c'est comment on fait pour arriver à
faire des molécules qui sont enchevêtrés
comme ça et en fait ce serait compliqué
et pendant longtemps la seule méthode
qu'on avait c'est qu'en fait on faisait
des molécules en cercle comme ça et puis
ont parié sur le fait que de temps en
temps par coup de bol comme quand on les
faisait que et que les cercles se
refermait par coup de bol on pouvait
espérer en avoir deux qu'ils soient
enchevêtrées c'était on savait faire
voilà c'est catena mais c'était très
très très inefficace et donc tout là
toute la beauté du travail de l'équipe
de sauvages à strasbourg ça a été de
trouver une manière de faire ces
molécules à de manière beaucoup plus
efficace avec un rendement de 2 90% et
c'est pour ça qu'en fin c'est vraiment
un vrai prix nobel de chimie
je dis ça parce que de temps en temps le
prix nobel de chimie on
plutôt pour des travaux de biologie
moléculaire que l'on peut paraît
vraiment récompensée avec le prix nobel
de médecine alors on leur donne le prix
nobel de chimie
là c'est un vrai prix nobel de chimie
est c'est à dire c'est des gens qui ont
qui ont trouvé l'art du chimiste c'est
de trouver une voix de synthèse pour
fabriquer des molécules et donc et on
voit là l'équipe de sauvage a trouvé une
voix de synthèse
c'est à dire un certain nombre des raids
des réactifs une procédure des
catalyseurs etc
pour arriver à fabriquer des molécules
enchevêtrés donc ça a commencé avec des
caténaires qu'on savait déjà fermé que
grâce à lui on a pu faire de manière
beaucoup plus efficace
et puis ensuite un certain nombre
d'autres types de molécules tu as
vraiment ouvert des portes sur sur
quelle est la manière de faire la
synthèse de molécules comme ça et on
peut citer d'autres exemples
par exemple est ce qu'on appelle les
rotax ain où cette fois on ne sait pas
tout à fait ça c'est plutôt faut
imaginer une d'une longue chaîne plutôt
plutôt droite
et puis une molécule plus tôt circulaire
qu'on arriverait à mettre dessus et puis
on met des choses ici pour bloquer donc
on a quelque chose qui peut tourner
comme autour d'un axe voilà ça a été la
grande contribution de sauvages de
trouver de trouver toutes ces mois de
cette voix de synthèse qui ont pu
permettre de faire des molécules qui
avaient des enchevêtrements et des
formes qui était très différente de ce
qu'on savait faire avant et donc il a
notamment fait des choses avec des
topologies un peu bizarre donc ça
parlera aux mathématiciens qui aime bien
la théorie des noeuds ou la théorie
détresse par exemple des molécules qui
en fait avait la forme de noeud c'est à
dire qu'ils se qui se renouent est sur
elle même et donc ça ça ouvert la voie à
plein de travaux sur les sur les
machines moléculaires et 1 d un des
personnes qui a été récompensée
notamment avec lui s'appelle ben fait
ringard et il a été le premier à arriver
à exploiter tous ses principes pour
faire des mouvements qui commence à être
vraiment complexe et donc notamment il a
fait ce qu'on a appelé un peu un peu
malicieusement la première nano voiture
ces structures avec vraiment des des
quelque chose qui peut s'apparenter à
des roues et qui est capable de bouger
alors c'est quelque chose qui est quand
même important c'est que comme comme une
vraie machine
ces molécules qui sont capables d'avoir
des mouvements elles vont pas faire des
mouvements comme ça spontanément
gratuitement entre guillemets c'est à
dire que comme une vraie machine ils
font les alimenter avec de l'énergie et
notamment les
et les structures qui ont été créés par
faire un gars sont capables de réagir
par exemple à un stimulus qui peut être
qui peut être une impulsion lumineuse ou
voilà ce genre de choses
il ya un truc qu'il faut dire c'est que
en matière de machines moléculaires on
est absolument ridicule par rapport à ce
que sait faire la vie c'est à dire qu'on
connaît tout un tas de merveilleuses
machines moléculaires qui sont dans nos
corps ont l'exemple le plus simple c'est
ce qui se passe avec nos muscles nos
muscles sont des machines sont capables
de réagir et d'effectuer un mouvement en
réponse un stimuli en dépensant
l'énergie et tout ça et parce qu' il
existe des molécules très très complexe
qui ont et qui sont synthétisés par par
notre corps des protéines tout ça qu'ils
sont capables de faire ces mouvements
très compliqué donc en fait le des
machines moléculaires on en connaît déjà
plein elles sont très compliquées c'est
la vie qui les a créés vous pouvez
penser à d'autres choses comme par
exemple je sais pas moi le flagelle du
spermatozoïde voilà un spermatozoïde
c'est une
c'est une jolie machine moléculaire et
donc on est vraiment à l'enfance de ce
domaine là par rapport à ce qu'on sait
qu'on pourrait faire s'ils ont maîtrisé
un peu tous les principes qui était
derrière
et donc voilà il y avait certainement se
passer des choses dans ce domaine là et
on peut déjà imaginer un certain
d'applications notamment appartement on
sera capable de faire des molécules qui
serait peut-être un petit peu plus
intelligente qui serait capable
d'effectuer certaines fonctions de faire
peut-être de ses trilles et certaines
cibles etc voilà il ya des perspectives
énormes mais encore une fois on n'en est
qu'au début et et tout ça c'est grâce à
l'art des chimistes qui sont calés de
trouver des voix de synthèse très
original pour arriver à vraiment
produire ces molécules parce que voilà
la clé c'est pas juste de les imaginer
comme ça sur le sur le papier de les
dessiner c'est comment on fait pour les
fabriquent voilà alors je vais passer au
dernier prix qui est le prix nobel de
physique
alors ça va être peut-être le plus le
plus complexe des 3 alors c'est un prix
qui a été décerné cette année à des gens
qui font de la physique théorique
vous savez que moi dans le passé j'ai
fait de la physique théorique et quand
je parle de physique théorique sur la
chaîne généralement je vous parle de
physique des particules de cosmologie de
théorie quantique des champs ou là des
choses qui sont liées plutôt à ce que
c'est que la matière au niveau
fondamental et en fait ça pourrait
laisser croire que la physique théorique
c'est que ça en fait c'est pas que ça
il ya notamment tout un tas de travaux
qui sont vraiment très intéressant et
très riche dans un domaine qu'on appelle
la physique de la matière condensée donc
la matière condensée c'est quoi c'est
pour faire simple c'est ces liquides et
les solides et donc il ya beaucoup de
travaux en physique de la matière
condensée de travaux théoriques
expérimentaux au 6 mai et est ce qui est
amusant c'est que c'est un peu le
contraire de ce qu'on fait dans la
physique théorique des particules par
exemple en physique des particules
on prend des choses complexes puis on
essaye de les casser morceau le plus
petit possible pour essayer de voir
c'est quoi les constituants élémentaires
dont c'est vraiment de de descendre à
l'échelle la plus petite pour voir de
quoi tout ça est fait en physique de la
matière condensée c'est un peu la
prochain vers 7 heures on prend des
élèves des particules présentes des
atomes dont on pense qu'on sait à peu
près comment ils se comportent on les
met ensemble dans un pouf air liquide ou
pour faire un cristallin solide
cristallin et on essaye de voir quels
sont les propriétés qui apparaissent et
donc c'est une discipline qui est
vraiment très intéressante alors
qu'elles commençaient ya longtemps on a
commencé à s'intéresser d'un point de
vue théorique aux propriétés des
liquides et des solides bas
principalement au début du 20e siècle et
notamment grâce à l'émergence de la
mécanique quantique et les premières
choses qu'on a étudié qu'on a compris
relativement vite par exemple c'est tout
simplement pourquoi certains corps
certains solide son conducteur de
l'électricité et pas d'autres pourquoi
il ya des métaux il ya des isolants donc
ça c'est des choses qu'on a qu'on a pu
comprendre avec une théorie qu'on
appelle notamment la théorie des bandes
qui est dérivé de la mécanique quantique
et qui nous a permis aussi de comprendre
quelque chose qui est très important
c'est les semi conducteurs donc les
semi-conducteurs c'est pour faire simple
c'est à mi-chemin entre entre un métal
est un isolant les semi-conducteurs
c'est super important puisque c'est
grâce aux semi-conducteurs qu'on fait
des transistors donc
et de l'électronique ont fait des
microprocesseurs et c'est donc si jamais
vous êtes capable de regarder cette
vidéo sur votre ordinateur sur votre
téléphone tout ça c'est grâce aux
semi-conducteurs si on fait les panneaux
photovoltaïques c'est grâce aux
semi-conducteurs voilà c'est essentiel
dans le monde aujourd'hui donc le
prochain qui me dit que la physique
théorique ça sert à rien voilà vous
savez des choses qu'on maîtrise assez
bien
depuis on va dire la première moitié du
20e siècle et est en fait c'est des
choses qui ont été assez facile toutes
proportions gardées sur le plan
théorique parce que quand on considère
par exemple un métal qui conduit
l'électricité on se rend compte que pour
comprendre comment il fonctionne
on peut simplement considérer les
électrons comme étant des objets un peu
indépendant c'est à dire qu'on part du
principe que les électrons
n'interagissent pas trop il se voit pas
trop en quelque sorte les uns les autres
et finalement ça fonctionne et c'est
bien ça permet de comprendre comment
fonctionnent les métaux de comprendre
comment fonctionnent les isolants et les
semi conducteurs dans une certaine
mesure
en fait il existe tout un tas de
domaines où on peut plus ignorer ça
c'est qu'on peut plus faire comme si les
électrons ne voyez pas les uns les
autres
c'est ce qu'on appelle parfois le
domaine des fermions fortement corrélés
et c'est un sujet extrêmement difficile
parce que si vous prenez un morceau de
solides il ya un paquet d'électrons
dedans et donc si tous les électrons
elles interagissent avec tous les
électrons
ça fait un candidat mr d'interaction qui
est vraiment très compliqué à
appréhender
alors pourquoi je vous parle de tout ça
je veux en venir au sujet du prix nobel
une des choses qu'on étudie beaucoup
quand on fait de la physique de la
matière condensée
c'est notamment les phases de la matière
par une phase de la matière ont dû
classiquement voilà il y en a 3 liquide
solide gazeux parfois on vous rajoute le
plasma landes il y en a quatre
en fait c'est pas vrai il y en a
beaucoup plus que ça rien n'a pas que ni
trois ni quatre il ya tout un tas de
deux faces de la matière qu'on connaît
mais qui sont des phases qu'on appelle
plutôt exotique est la raison pour
laquelle sont exotiques c'est qu'on les
croise pas tous les jours et notamment
on les croise que quand on descend des
températures très basses
alors il ya deux exemples qui sont très
importants c'est la supraconductivité
est la superfluidité supraconductivité
c'est quoi c'est que le fait que
certains solide quand on les refroidit
à des températures très basses se
mettent à conduire l'électricité sans
aucune résistance
et ça c'est quelque chose d'assez
d'assez original d'acea normal on a
envie de penser parce que même les
métaux qui conduisent très bien
l'électricité en fait toujours une
petite résistance a alors que non les
supraconducteurs
ils ont une résistance nul c'est à dire
qu'ils propagent le courant sans aucune
résistance et donc ça c'est assez
formidable et ça un certain nombre
d'applications notamment pour faire par
exemple dans des irm ou un certain
nombre de transports à lévitation et
c'est donc la supraconductivité est
l'autre l'autre sujet qui est assez
intéressant dont on entend souvent
parler c'est ce qu'on appelle la
superfluidité donc c'est un peu un
cousin d'un phénomène cousin donc là
c'est plutôt dans des liquides qui vont
en dessous d'une certaine température
par exemple ça se produit avec l'hélium
se mettre à couler sans aucune viscosité
sans aucun frottement donc le liquide
devient super fluide
donc ça c'est des phénomènes qui sont
très intrigant et qu'on a du coup voulu
comprendre sur le plan théorique et par
exemple la supraconductivité en fait on
a une théorie de la supraconductivité
mais elle n'explique que les phénomènes
de supraconductivité en dessous d'une
certaine température pense pas tout à
fait ça mais ça n'explique qu'une partie
de la supraconductivité d'un c'est
seulement la supraconductivité de
certains corps et il existe tout un tas
de solides qui sont supraconducteurs des
températures plus élevées que ce que
prédit ray la théorie dont je viens de
parler et cela on sait pas du tout
expliqué pourquoi ils sont
supraconducteurs pourquoi cette
supraconductivité qu'on appelle haute
température existe alors on dit haute
température mais haute température ça
reste quand même très très froid mais et
ça c'est une question c'est une question
qui est vraiment extrêmement
intéressante parce que imaginer qu'on
comprenne mieux ça et qu'on soit capable
de fabriquer des supraconducteurs
peut-être qui fonctionnerait à
température ambiante ça permettrait de
transporter du courant à température
ambiante 100 perd donc ça serait
vraiment quelque chose d'incroyable et
la supraconductivité à haute température
aujourd'hui personne la comprend
personne n'a de théories qui vraiment
explique la supraconductivité à haute
température
je peux vous dire que le premier qui va
se pointer avec une théorie convaincante
de ça il peut directement prendre son
billet pour stockholm est allé chercher
son prix nobel
donc on en est on en est pas encore là
mais il ya tout un tas d'autres
phénomènes qui sont un peu
connexes à sa qui concerne des
changements de phase un peu exotique
comme ça qu'on essaie d'étudier dans
l'espoir que voilà ça va nous amener à
une meilleure compréhension de ce qui se
passe dans cette lancée
non c'est notamment dans les
supraconducteurs et donc voilà pourquoi
je vous parle de tout ça c'est que les
trois qui ont eu le prix nobel de
physique cette année donc il s'appelle
look austerlitz tall s et haldane ils
ont travaillé sur certaines phases
certain changement de phase
un peu exotique de la matière et alors
c'est vraiment exotiques parce que mon
d'une part ça se produit aussi à des
températures qui sont très basses 1
toujours et en plus ils ont étudié
spécifiquement des systèmes qui sont en
ce qu'on appelle en base dimension leurs
bases dimension ça veut dire en deux
dimensions ou dans une dimension
alors ça peut paraître un peu un peu
stupide parce que on sait très bien
qu'on vit dans un monde en trois
dimensions donc la matière est en trois
dimensions mais en fait il existe un
certain nombre de systèmes qui sont des
systèmes en deux dimensions
on peut citer par exemple si on fait des
films très mince par exemple de
supraconducteurs ils vont se comporter
comme des comme les films en deux
dimensions
ça marche aussi par exemple avec des
films de super fluide et aussi
maintenant on est même capable de faire
des structures qui soit vraiment
bidimensionnel on a pas mal parlé ces
dernières années du graphène que le prix
nobel je sais plus il ya quelques années
d'ailleurs graphène c'est vraiment une
structure bidimensionnel c'est une
feuille qui a de carbone dont qui a un
atome d'épaisseur et donc ces gens là
voilà ont étudié des changements de
phase un peu exotique qui se passait
dans des décors en deux dimensions et en
ayant une dimension et alors je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails parce que c'est
vraiment compliqué si j'ai le courage
j'essaierai de faire un billet de blog
sur le sujet je mettrai le dire quelque
part donc si le lien marche pas c'est
que j'ai pas eu le courage de faire le
billet mais ce qu'ils ont fait c'est
qu'ils ont ils ont d'un point de vue
théorique trouver des changements de
phase 1 notamment un type de changement
de phase qu'on appelle la transition
captées pour kostelic teurlay ce qui en
fait à des propriétés qu'on n'avait
jamais imaginé avant on pense pas que ce
type de changement de phase pouvait
exister et ils l'ont trouvée sur le plan
théorique et ensuite on a fait un
certain nombre d'expériences qui ont
permis de vérifier mais qu'en fait ils
avaient raison que ça marchait vraiment
comme ça dans des systèmes certain
système bi dimensionnelle et en plus il
ya quelque chose d'assez d'assez magique
avec ses théories sur les changements de
phase
c'est qu'il ya un peu une notion
d'universalité c'est à dire qu'une fois
qu'on a compris un modèle
il peut être suffisamment génériques et
s'appliquer à tout un tas de systèmes
différents et donc il ya tout un tas de
systèmes qui ont l'air assez peu reliés
les uns aux autres comme des films de
supraconducteurs des films d'hélium bien
des espèces de réseaux planaire de
jonction supraconductrice qui en fait
suivre tous la théorie de la de la
transition cat et voilà donc donc ils
ont vraiment découvert des nouveaux
types de changements de phase dans la
matière donc assez exotique on appelle
ça parfois les faces topologique parce
que pour des raisons que je vous passe
la manière dont on décrit les phases et
les changements de pas phase fait appel
un certain nombre de notions plutôt de
topologie voilà ce qu'ils connaissent la
topologie en mathématiques donc voilà
donc ça c'était pour le prix nobel de
physique
voilà j'espère que ce petit descriptif
vous aura permis d'y voir un peu plus
clair sur quels étaient les prix nobel
de cette année et au delà des gens à qui
on les donne parce qu'on les donne
toujours à quelques personnes alors
qu'il ya toujours des tas d'équipés
derrière et c'est de vous faire
comprendre pourquoi on considère que ces
sujets sont importants voilà parce que
le canton fils le nobel c'est parce que
c'est parce que c'est quelque chose
d'important et je voudrais essayer de
vous faire sentir pourquoi ces choses
étaient importantes
voilà et ben donc comme je vous le
disais je ferai peut-être un petit
billet pour expliquer un petit peu plus
le prix nobel de physique
d'ici là si vous voulez une vidéo sur un
mode un petit peu plus normal enfin pas
tout à fait normal un petit peu
différent j'ai collaboré il n'ya pas
longtemps avec la chaîne string theory
donc j'ai fait un petit épisode avec lui
il y en aura d'autres mais je fais un
petit épisode avec eux sur sur
l'acoustique et la physique du son dont
je vous recommande de vous pouvez vous
pouvez l'acheter un oeil
voilà il peut un d'ici là je vous dis à
très bientôt et continuer d'aimer la
science merci à bientôt